[Musique]
merci lettre avec tous les chefs c'est
touche pas à mon poste que le before est
aujourd'hui 8 mars
qu'est-ce que tu aujourd'hui c'est la
journée de la femme il a entendu alors
est on n'a pas attendu la journée de la
femme pour embrasser des femmes leur
dire qu'on les aime bien entendu les
aubry sont ressorties sur les réseaux
des tweets que vous aviez écrit entre
juillet et septembre 2010 est vous avez
quel âge à l'époque dont 17 ans et en 17
ans des tweets parfois ironique très
provocant qui ont scandalisé beaucoup de
monde
il ya eu des commentaires jugés
homophobes voilà moi je m'excuse déjà je
tiens à dire à toutes les personnes
qu'on complète aux français ce que je
comprends ta carrément bas je m'excuse
je n'ai pas cessé
c'est une connerie vous avez voulu faire
le malin à l'époque moi j'étais sûr que
j'étais sur internet avec des potes on
rigolait et c'est de l'humour c'est
d'humour nul cdu seconde troisième
dixième degré c'est nul quoi commencer
ça s'étire à moyen terme d'accor
services a déjà je me rappelais même pas
les avoir posté qu'est-ce que tu réponds
ça est-ce que ce que tata émis en aucun
cas j'ai souhaité du mal et encore moi
ma meilleure année jamais je souhaitais
de mal bien mais qu'un jamais le
problème c'est que j'ai été contraint
par quelques notes qu'elle me soutirer
le devoir des fois dire ah non mais il
faut faire ça parce que sinon tu vas
parilla ce que j mais moi je veux plus y
arriver elle voulait dire des chaussures
maeva sur mywa ou sur d'autres personnes
mais elle se servait de 18 ses bottes
meilleur ami mais ça existe a même
enregistré des notes tenir je vais
pouvoir la tenir à travers ça et comme
ça elle va forcément continuer à payer
parce que si ça sera au grand jour ça va
être un carnage
moi j'étais contraint de donner cet
argent pour qu'ils me laissent
tranquille parce que j'avais peur aussi
pour ma vie j'avais peur pour ma maman
il était déjà venu à plusieurs fins à
plusieurs reprises récupérer des chèques
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire à l'heure d'aujourd'hui ce
que j'ai envie de dire c'est déjà de
m'excuser auprès des marseillais de
toutes les personnes qui ont été
impliquées par sept par cette affaire
parce que malgré tout ils n'ont rien
demandé
je m'aperçois que vous êtes lâche sur le
plateau de pascal praud vous ne vous
aimez pas on est des moins que rien ça
nous insultent ici vous arrivez vous
avez peur de nous donc non pas du tout
procès soit du tout les gens rampaient
vous allez leur idée si rooney qui vous
invite donc ce n'est pas moi qui me suis
fait dire ils partent jouer quelques
années j'étais encore en quoi c'est du
coup je m'en rappelle plus trop beaucoup
ont succédé des passants et puis les
pompiers - ensuite ils ont annoncé
qu'une opération
et puis après je suis intervenu alors tu
es c'est un déferlement de coûts on l'a
vu un geste a pensé à ce moment là ce
que tu t'es dit à un moment je vais je
peut-être perdre la vie si je pense que
sans penser je ressentais la peur de la
mort quand même parce que ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est pas rien quand même
puis les réceptions tournoi qu'il ne
situe pas tout aliment c'est le crâne
ouvert dont tu plantes sont partout
moi j'ai senti que j'avais du sang sur
les mains sur la tête je n'ai jamais
coupé le contact avec carla elle n'a
jamais coupé le contact avec moi de 2015
jusqu'en janvier 2021 ce qui m'a dit que
c'est vous qui nous a dit que c'est vous
qui l'avez rappelé après on la voit pas
du tout je peux apporter les preuves
d'ailleurs que j'ai donné il ya une
enquête
comme vous le savez j'ai 24 ans court
donc moi j'ai apporté tout ça à la
justice ils les ont je n'ai le contact
n'a jamais été coupé entre moi et mon
ancienne cliente alors parce qu il yal
avez dit que vous l'aviez au contact et
et qu'elle s'était retrouvé face à 10
personnes
absolument pas
[Musique]
on est en direct sur skyrock et l'âge et
la clé usb j'ai dit à cédric et on dit
qu'est ce que tu as même une petite de
gad elmaleh dans trente secondes je
passe sur l'antenne je bosse avant que
la balle est dans toute la france
c'est énorme s'est mal passé c'est
magnifique
attention il m'a lancé
les bâlois ont roulé en direct au
skyrock
je confirme 80 s'est passé au partir
également regarder tpm mais au fond elle
vous pouvez parler d'eux pour la
première fois mais ttp pascal gad
elmaleh le pottok arabité et vous savez
quoi
on va diffuser à saluer ce que les
autres leaders de sky là en haïti camtel
magnifique sur le titre c'est le titre
étant donné le morceau s'appelle
bidonvilles simplement ses champs mais
je leur réponds fait comme vous pouvez
mais faites attention à vous je suis
personne pour dire aller porter plainte
même si ce serait la meilleure chose à
faire
évidemment c'est tellement violent et
c'est tellement tu es en main dans un
engrenage été avec un bourreau qui te
met plus bas que terre et à ce moment là
les gens ils peuvent pas comprendre tour
c'est très violent c'est à dire que on
quand on te dit tu es une merde tu es
crois parce que tu es lobotomisés est en
permanence on te dit tu es comme ça tu
fais ça je t'aime plus que tout le monde
autour et et seulement ça arrive à des
femmes très très forte parce que j'ai
une personnalité qui est un petit peu
atypique et on pourra développer ça dans
un autre si tu veux mais je laisse un
petit peu passé ça et je me dis que ce
serait trop injuste que que le mec ne
comprennent pas à quoi donc jeu j'essaye
de de lui dire les choses il comprend
pas et ça se passe en fait le mec il
n'arrive pas à s'exprimer ou je sais pas
et est il que c'est tombé je m'étais
fait opérer des deux pieds j'avais deux
pieds je ne pouvais pas marcher j'étais
vraiment en même temps les deux pieds et
du coup il m'a poussé il m'a mis par
terre il m'a bastonné par dessus mais
c'était terrifiant quoi
à la contacter pour qu'elle fasse des
travaux que d'adressé pas faire c'est ça
c'est ça avoir d'arrêt voilà pascoe mais
j'ai jamais fait de travaux pour elle
d'accord d'accord
doc word à quel est votre conclusion
alors ce soir que vous avez à dire alors
bon tout le monde c'est vrai c'est
mitigé tout le monde dit c'est faux ils
sont pour la team mashala kim machin la
corse est bilan mais je vais vous dire
la vérité il ya réellement du racket ya
réellement durable et y'a pas que carla
c'est ça c'est pour ça que chez nrj ya
les gens du peuple qui a des clients
prêts à combien de reprises elle a dit
si tu me payes pas telle somme je vais
montrer à ton mec que tu m'a ramené sa
photo tous les lui faire un travail
parce qu'elle prend tous les coordonnées
elle pose la question ils travaillent ou
qui ce qui fait elle fait du chantage
c'est tout le temps c'est pas eu c'est
pas dit c'est plusieurs dents mais chez
un pote et elle lui a dit mais on a
appris que très tard avec que tu veux
dire lituanie je suis pas un garçon ou
une fille et pourquoi comment tu le
ressens tu es ça parce que c'est que
c'est c'est si c'est intéressant de
savoir comment tu comment tu l'a
ressenti c'est pas facile à expliquer
puisque ce que tu as cuitot et tu l'a
ressenti à quel âge auras 4 5 en trois 3
ans ah ouais et commencer comment ça se
passe comment ça c'est en fait je pense
qu'elle était elle s'est rendue compte
de 7-2 de son mal-être vers 3 ans à
l'entrée à l'école d'accord mais je
pense que depuis toujours elle
s'identifier comme une fille en fait non
le voit maintenant à posteriori ne
savais pas du tout comment ça allait
être pressée ça et puis et puis nous on
était forcément hyper inquiet parce
qu'une enfants de 6 ou 7 1 qui explique
toutes les façons dont elle avait pensé
pour se tuer face tf1 croit parce que je
sais qu'elle a et c est dingue de penser
ça ton jeune âge tu as traversé une
période de dépression mali qu'est ce que
tu me paraît que tu voulais plus vivre
comme ça pire que ça va s'arranger pour
toi le plus important je le dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tu sois heureuse et ait
réussi à trouver pourquoi tu étais dans
un mal être et ses parents ont été
formidables et kits ont suivi et qu'ils
ont tout fait pour que ce heureuse et ça
c'est juste de la paf
1 cd papier et ça va être vite être
réglé d'autant plus que vous avez la loi
avec vous mr sa foire vous n'avez ce
soir est dorénavant que mon pur mépris
[Rires]
quoiqu'il ça va sortir il nous a
prévenus au préalable le dimanche moi
j'ai pris ma voiture je suis parti chez
carlyle kevin donc je suis allé voir
kevin pour m'expliquer avec lui pour
l'entente et pour essayer d'être là
avait enfin les crises qui est normal
j'ai fait mon travail des agences en
fait un de chalus à côté de lui et on
s'est dit une chose c'est que si ça sort
pas de toute manière
comment on peut empêcher que sa sortie
nous a dit que ça sortirait quoi qu'il
arrive ça va sortir ils allaient le
symbole du coin il n'a pas de ses choix
risque non mais je vais me sortir vous à
10 cadets sortir oui toutes les autres
je les ai convaincus sur et audio de
carla en train de lancer des sorts des
choses comme ça il nous a dit les choses
et les a fait écouter aux marseillais
avant que ça sorte
donc c'est vrai que marseille était très
énervé on comprenait pas trop pourquoi
sont là mais parce qu'ils avaient
entendu avant que ça sorte
donc moi la seule chose que j'ai demandé
à marc plata avec kevin parce que
j'étais avec kevin à ce moment là on lui
a dit écoute
ok tu va le sortir quand il a dit on va
sortir maintenant ce après midi on lui a
demandé s'il te plaît à temps qu'on
mette carla à l'abri avec sa famille qu
elles sont entourées par qu'elle était
seul au moment où on était avec le
téléphone y avait pas avec nous donc on
a juste demandé kevin et moi à main
blata d'attendre qu'elle soit auprès de
sa famille pour sortir il a été
bouleversée elle a dit oui et il a fait
voilà excusez moi je peux intervenir
oui tu l'invités oui l'autre jour et la
nuit sur les réseaux sociaux qu'elle
voulait un adversaire la buba oui on
coupe et au revoir
alors alors malheur d'avoir on n'a pas
le mot beauvallet qu'aujourd'hui on voit
juste jeu terminé en moins envie loana
lé vous avez appelé quand elle était en
détresse il ya quelques jours
hier quand même quelque chose on s'en
bat les classes emballé qu on s'y
attendait qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
voulait dire quoi ça je voulais dire
comme ça que géraldine
[Musique]